my viewers that I think Nicola should be
considering whether it would be the
right thing for her to do for her
commitment to the party and also for the
smooth running of the government because
I think this could be seen as a little
bit of a distraction right now and for
her to resign her party membership
clearly this is a very serious situation
I think members like myself will be I
think some of them will be quite sad at
what they're seeing and they're going to
be very concerned about the impact that
this is having on the party
but the SNP has been around for a long
time we're just coming up to 90 years as
a political party I think we can
navigate through this and I think it is
incumbent on the leadership to take
decisive action as well though